[Music]
hi I'm so I'm Carol and like I don't
just said I work at BuzzFeed
so um most of you probably know what
BuzzFeed is but if you don't I'll give
you a quick overview so those feed is a
media and tech company so we produce a
lot of content and then we distribute
that content over a variety of platforms
so some quick stats we basically get a
lot of views on snapchat YouTube
Facebook and in general we get 9 billion
total views a month so the tech part
really comes in to how we take the
content that our editors create and how
we carry that so different audiences can
see different things that they're
interested in so all that's to say we
have a lot of views but obviously we do
want to keep growing so that's kind of
where me and my team come in so I am on
the network growth team so our goal is
to just keep growing the website so
BuzzFeed has a lot of different
destinations but our goal is to go
across all those destinations not just
news not just tasty not just any of our
other media brands so there's a couple
like extremely simple ways you can think
about growth so one is to I guess
increase your user base in general and
then another is to basically increase
how your users interact with the website
so this talk about like related content
will be mainly focused on the second so
surprisingly like when I joined I was
really surprised that we didn't have any
related content so for example like and
this is actually something I used to do
I would kind of look at different ways
to decorate my room and I would be
interested in seeing more content about
that but then if I looked on the
different recirculation areas of our
website none of that was relevant at all
in fact the other recirculation units
are populated and there's a number of
ways they're populated but
some of them are based on click-through
some of them are based on the number of
like incoming traffic they're receiving
of our specific time window some of them
are just like reverse chronological so
the only way that you could find belated
content was if an editor chose to
manually curate some links and put them
at the bottom of the page but that
obviously is kind of not the best way to
go about it since we have a huge content
library so editors don't necessarily
know what is the best thing to put there
and they also might biased towards their
own work so that's kind of why we
realized that it'd be a good idea to
have an automated way to generate these
things and we also also hypothesized
that doing so would increase our pages
per session and also how much time our
users spent per browsing session so just
to give like a like a little bit more
historical context like I started on the
Aza's team which is like art beauty i
style destination and when we talked to
our editors they also had like the
similar suggestion so i originally
started working on this model using as
is only data and so my training corpus
was only like a few thousand at the time
so that kind of I guess informed how I
went did the process a little but
basically I created the model with as is
my corpus grew so our results got a
little better then I ended up moving to
like all of network growth so then I
expanded the model to just like more of
the website and then eventually we
production iced it so mmm I'm just gonna
kind of go over which models that I
considered and then give like a pretty
high-level overview of them so in our
case like we were we're just interested
in figuring out like overall content
similarity so we're like any text
processing task you're basically trying
to find out how you can convert words
and other documents into vectors so that
way you can compare them numerically so
there's a lot of different ways to do
that there's count based methods and
predictive based methods
so for cafes you would basically be
computing like count statistics so like
frequency co-occurrence and then
basically reducing them down to get a
dense representation of each document
and for predictive methods you would
actually be trying to predict the word
or their neighbors and then learning
embeddings that way so I chose to look
at where Tyvek which is obviously very
popular fast X dot effect and then two
topic models so I think it's like
easiest to start with where Tyvek
because so many things well at least the
other two models I used are very closely
related to them or related to it so
we're Tyvek it's basically a show neuro
network
it's trained on a task and you use the
hidden layer as your embeddings so it's
kind of similar to how if you have an
autoencoder you use like the hidden
layer to basically represent like a
condensed version of your input so you
can either train a word Tyvek neural net
using the Skip RAM model or the
continuous bag of words model so in the
terms of skip Graham you're basically
trying to predict your context words
given a target words and continuous
backup words is the opposite of that so
given what we learn from this as you can
imagine because we're learning about the
context what you'll have is in theory
you'll have embeddings that then are
similar for words that share similar
contexts one really interesting thing
about this model that also made it like
so widely used is that it's really
computationally efficient so instead of
having there's like a couple of
techniques so you didn't have to update
like a huge huge set of like hidden
layer weights using like- sampling so
basically only up some updating like a
small sample of weights based on how
frequently where it's occur so you can
kind of like from where Tyvek I think
they're just like follow up papers and
like methods written for dr. Beck
fast text so dr. Beck is it's kind of
it's basically like we're Tyvek but
you're adding in document context so
you're adding in a document ID there's
also two variants of it distributed bag
of bars and then the distributed memory
model so one of them includes a document
vector as part of the input layer and
learns the document concept through
training and then the other one you
basically have an input layer of only
document IDs and you learn a document
vector based on being trained on
predicting like the probability of words
that occur within that document and then
the other one fast text is one that I
wanted to use because as I mentioned I
had a very small training corpus and so
like I didn't have like a whole like
there are some words that occurred like
very infrequently and fast text because
it doesn't treat a word as like a single
entity and learns more sub word
information and I figured it was like a
good model to test but basically fast
text represents words as the sum of
their engrams and you can see like an
example of Li and grams of where in the
slide and then quickly just going in to
topic models which were the last two
models that I tried and the reason I did
topic models is because word to back and
fast text they both give you word
embeddings but in my case I was really
looking for like a document embedding so
that's why I use dr. back and topic
models to get document vectors so you
can probably just start with like LSI
because it is I think a bit of the
simpler of the two so you have a sparse
document turn matrix and that can just
be like represented with counts or with
their term frequency and forced document
frequency values then you can use
singular value decomposition to
decompose that matrix into a document
term matrix the singular values and a
term topic matrix so then when you have
your document term matrix what you have
is then your document represented as a
vector of
you're like with the probabilities of
all the topics within that document and
one drawback to this is that you can't
really interpret what those topics are
so that kind of leads you in to the next
one
so Lda is just actually I think it's
easier to describe like problem like
probabilistic LSA because Oda is
basically a variant of that but more or
less you are generating your document
topic matrix and your word topic matrix
based on a probability distribution and
so Lda then attempts to generate your
original matrix using the probability
distributions using a different prior
but what you do have is you do have
topics that you can interpret but also
like it you get a document that's
represented by the topics and all the
probabilities within so I have all these
models and here's kind of a summary of
how they all performed so I was kind of
lucky and that we did have about like
1700 articles that had editor curated
links for them and those often those are
mostly on news articles so I did think
those would actually be pretty relevant
because the writers of news articles
generally are kind of like experts and I
guess what they're writing about and
also because news topics are more timely
like they don't have to worry about like
sorting through like a huge corpus so I
kind of looked at this in terms of
precision recall and then also like the
general ranking of where editor
generated recommendation is ranked in my
list or in the model generated list and
then also the number of articles were at
least one of the recommendations from
the editor was found and the model
generated recommendations so as you can
see the highs promote highest performing
models were a combination of the word
embeddings mixed with tf-idf so just a
quick point about the word embeddings a
common like industry baseline is just to
average of the embeddings and
into a document betting but that worked
okay for me but I also did I also
instead waited the word embeddings with
their tf-idf weights and that worked out
a lot better for me not just looking at
these metrics but I also read through
like a lot of the rap animations on my
own so I also did a t-sne visualization
this isn't gonna be super super
thoughtful but you can kind of see what
the clusters are so like the yellow
cluster here is like or the blue cluster
here it's like shopping content I
actually kind of forget what this one is
but then this is recipes and then
there's Harry Potter the brown up top is
like politics so they all like we're
definitely easy to be interpreted if you
actually like kind of like look through
the titles and if anybody wants to see
the plotly just please ask me and so
then in the end my final model was just
a word Tyvek model embedded with an
embedding size of 160 come by and it
formed a document vector using tf-idf
weights and I guess I didn't really
mention what data I used exactly for
each of these documents but I used the
BuzzFeed title the little like byline
blurb description from the author of the
text and then I also used
I also enhanced it was like some of the
types that editors used and that just
basically became the post metadata that
I used to train all of this so here's
like an example of some of the
recommendations infinity war stuff I
also included one of the ones from
quizzes because the model actually does
work pretty well even when they're like
when there aren't that many like words
within the article which happens a lot
to us for quizzes and for a lot of like
BuzzFeed original content so now you can
just kind of talk about how we went to
production so one of the biggest
challenges here was that the service
that we deploy and run most of our
service of the
services on at BuzzFeed has like a three
gigabyte memory cap it might be four but
either way ours exceeded that so for the
batch training part of it we ended up
running it separately using a Google
cloud instance and so what happens is
that we pull off our post meta data from
our bigquery database that is not
updated real time so we have one process
that batch trains on everything in
bigquery and then we have another
process which is a cue reader that
basically captures all the buzzes like
in between training times
so during batch training we develop the
word effectors the tf-idf corpus and
then the phrase model that we use as
well and then we store all those
components into s3 then the key reader
listens for an event every time a new
post is published and then it reads from
the same as 3 model or site the same s3
bucket and it grabs the vectors the
tf-idf component and the phrase
component and then it generates like
recommendations based off those saved
models and then also whenever we update
any of the model files the cue reader
itself will automatically know - like
reload so it's always consuming like the
most recent copy oh and then after that
basically what the model comes up with
is we send another file with all of the
results to our Orchestrator api which
then stores all of this in Redis and
makes it available for the website to
like pull all the stuff that needs to
render so moving on to some results
finally um here we ran an a/b test over
two weeks it was kind of unlike a
smaller subset so we only ran it for
BuzzFeed original content so that didn't
include any like quizzes or tasty or
like news any of our media brand stuff
and we ran it for us edition only posts
but in general we did observe
significant results so we ran it for
like a number of metrics but I felt like
pages per session and time per session
were the ones that we wanted to test the
most we definitely saw like more of an
impact on desktop which not like
extremely surprising since our users on
desktop tend to have longer sessions
anyway but in any case all other metrics
perform pretty well including just like
the number of visits that the user had
over that time the number of sessions
the user had like not just within the
session but over the entire test period
so we ended up like we're only this
model out oh and then another quick
thing is we tested it with two different
variants one of them below our share bar
one of them above that was just to make
sure that like our share of metrics
weren't affected too much because the
idea was maybe if you click on one of
these things you forget to share an
article you meant to share but there
weren't any impacts there I okay
hopefully you can see that all right but
these are basically this click-through
rates for the different units that we
have on our webpage so the related
content unit is the blue line and it
currently has the highest click-through
rate out of the other recirculation
units on the page and after the a/b test
B also rolled it out to all English
posts still excluding any media brand
stuff and we're currently seeing about
three hundred thousand clicks predict
we're also going to be expanding it I
think to our app users because right now
this is only on BuzzFeed web so in
general what we've learned is that like
people do in general like they like
seeing related content which is not an
extremely groundbreaking observation but
it ended up working out pretty well in
this case but there's a lot more work
that we want to do with this
there's like a lot of other weren't
embedding and sentence embedding models
that like I've wanted to try to improve
some of these a little bit and we also a
big thing that I think is really
important is adding like more diversity
into these because right now when you go
into the website you'll see articles
that are like very very related but you
might get tired of like reading about
ways to decorate your room or buy more
clothes or something so in general
figuring out how we might be able to use
these vectors but also figure out a way
to show more diverse recommendations is
really important and also we might be
able to use these to help improve some
of like the personalization we still
have right now right now we use like a
collaborative filtering personalization
method and I don't think it's very well
tuned for the cold start problem so we
might be able to combine these with that
and then lastly it would be great to
also rank some of these not just based
on similarity but also based on how
they're clicking but right now the way
we have our website tracking set up we
are not quite there yet but in any case
there is a lot more we can do with this
and we are all very excited so that is
everything on my end thanks hello for
your point you just raise at the end
have you looked at all for your users
are they interested in the same types of
content like the person who's interested
in fashions also interested in politics
so recommend that so no we haven't but
that is kind of what I was thinking
about next in terms of introducing
diversity so what I was thinking was
basically using the document embeddings
clustering them and then looking at
which like topics were close together
and maybe recommending something after
that but there's definitely like
something that we are thinking about hi
thank you for the presentation first of
all how often would you train your model
we only train it every other day because
is right now the corpus is 66,000
articles and so like the weights won't
really change that much unless we're
introducing like a lot of new vocabulary
so every other day might even be like
not necessary but yeah we don't turn it
daily though so have you noticed for
certain like genres of articles this
engine not performing very well because
like when you start creating these
vector embeddings for each word that
kind of like captured the Conte's words
all fit within the same context but if a
certain genre has words that come from
like various different contexts in
general all like all come across your
whole website the average will actually
not represent what the article is about
anymore so I'm just wondering if you've
seen that in any place or observe that
behavior so do you mean like the quality
of the recommendations failing in
certain types of articles or the
performance of like how users interact
yeah so like the quality of the
recommendations for like specific genre
is not performing well and like have you
like had to deal with that issue so I
did see that a lot when I was using
averaging um especially for like out
quote like our culture related pieces so
like the averaging worked really well
when it was about just like a lot of
weight like a concentrated list of how
to do the same thing but on if you've
ever seen like a BuzzFeed list pose it
can be like extremely random so
averaging like I definitely saw it not
working out very well for a lot of those
things but when I applied the tf-idf
averaging like I see that a lot less I
guess like some places where the only
post I've seen it do really poorly for
is posts that have extremely sparse text
so you just like introduced a pote like
an interactive way to like pet your post
or something it's about like dogs and
either way like the only word is
like dog actually it's dog Oh and pet
and so it doesn't do and pant so then it
recommends a bunch of stuff about jeans
which obviously doesn't make any sense
so we're named entities like people's
names for example important factors and
did you find any embedding strategy to
be more successful dealing with that um
so what I did do was I compared using
not using like a phrase model to detect
common phrases and using one and so I
definitely because forward to back as
you probably know like you pick like a
window but the position of the word
within that window doesn't really matter
so using like the phrase or model helped
a lot with like named entities because
we do have a lot of posts with like
celebrity contact
hi I would like to know if you have
especially handling the really time
windows recommendation let's say during
the Christmas chime in work over Center
talk about Christmas tree but in January
you don't want to show that content
anymore
so you're filtering by maybe by label or
by jars so unfortunately we don't do
that right now but that is one of the
things that we want to incorporate
recency so we do have an ever another
like evergreen model that detects like
Evergreen Post so we're basically trying
to apply those tags unto here because
that is like a problem that comes up not
so much for like holiday related things
because people mostly read holiday
related things around holiday times but
it comes up for like timely like TV show
content for example
so we're basically so yes we do want to
start filtering it so that like you can
only really see like evergreen
recommendations
[Music]